"App misst Homosexualität",
"How gay are you", "wie schwul
oder lesbisch sind deine Gene?"
Für knappe 5 Euro
will dir diese App das verraten.
Laut Anbietern basiert die App auf
den Ergebnissen einer großen Studie
zur Genetik von Homosexualität,
die im August im renommierten Journal
"Science" veröffentlicht wurde.
Ist es denn überhaupt möglich?
Kann man anhand der Gene die sexuelle
Neigung eines Menschen ablesen?
- Heikle Frage.
(Mai) Das ist unser Funk-Kollege
Kostas vom Kanal Kostas Kind.
- Da ich selbst schwul bin,
beschäftige ich mich
mit solchen Fragen natürlich.
Es ist ja so: Einerseits wird
Homosexuellen oft vorgeworfen,
dass das nur ein "Lifestyle" wäre,
den sie sich ausgesucht haben,
oder eine Entscheidung,
die sie getroffen haben.
In so 'ner Situation wäre es cool,
wenn man sagen könnte:
Es ist nicht so, die Wissenschaft hat
gezeigt, dass man damit geboren wird.
Andererseits
kann das auch super gefährlich sein,
weil so ein Wissen auf jeden Fall
missbraucht werden kann.
Es ist nur ein Gedanke,
aber stellt euch vor,
man könnte
vor der Geburt feststellen,
ob ein Kind evtl. homosexuell wird.
Vielleicht würde dann in Ländern,
in denen Homosexualität illegal ist,
so ein Kind abgetrieben werden."
Die kurze Antwort auf die Frage,
steckt unsere Sexualität
in unseren Genen, ist: ja und nein.
Für die lange Antwort holt euch
einen Tee, macht es euch gemütlich,
wir steigen ein
in die faszinierende Wissenschaft
hinter der Erblichkeit
von Homosexualität.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2019)
Homosexuelles Verhalten, also Sex mit
einem gleichgeschlechtlichen Partner,
findet man, je nach Studie,
in 2-10% der Bevölkerung
und ist wahrscheinlich schon
so alt wie die Menschheit selbst.
Dokumentiert ist homosexuelles
Verhalten in verschiedensten Kulturen
und seit tausenden Jahren.
Auch im Tierreich ist Sex mit
einem gleichgeschlechtlichen Partner
alles andere als selten, sowohl in
Haltung als auch in freier Wildbahn.
Sex mit einem
gleichgeschlechtlichen Partner
ist also keine spezifisch menschliche
Erfindung oder Laune, aber:
Bei vielen Persönlichkeitsmerkmalen
kommt die alte
"nature versus nurture"-Debatte auf.
Ist Homosexualität erblich, also
nature, oder umweltbedingt, nurture?
Persönlichkeitsmerkmale
sind eigentlich immer beides,
also gleichzeitig
genetisch und umweltbedingt.
Das wissen wir u.a.
dank Zwillingsstudien.
Mehr dazu findet ihr in diesem Video,
wo ich die Erblichkeit
von Intelligenz ausführlich erkläre.
Warum Zwillinge?
Weil wir bei Zwillingen
den genetischen
Verwandtschaftsgrad kennen.
Also z.B. eineiige Zwillinge
haben zu 100% die gleiche DNA.
Bedeutet, wenn sich
diese eineiigen Zwillingen
in irgendwelchen Persönlichkeits-
merkmalen unterscheiden,
müssen diese Unterschiede
umweltbedingt sein.
D. h. jetzt aber nicht,
dass diese Eigenschaft an sich
komplett umweltbedingt ist.
Nehmt das Beispiel Intelligenz,
also eineiige Zwillinge
können unterschiedliche IQ's haben.
Dieser IQ-Unterschied
ist umweltbedingt.
Aber Intelligenz an sich
kann natürlich auch genetisch sein.
Und wie groß
dieser genetische Anteil ist,
können wir nur herausfinden,
wenn wir die Zwillinge
mit Menschen vergleichen,
die nicht die gleiche DNA haben.
Also vergleicht man eine Gruppe
eineiiger Zwillinge
mit einer Gruppe
zweieiiger Zwillinge.
Zweieiige Zwillinge haben nämlich
im Mittel zu 50% die gleiche DNA.
Im Fall Intelligenz
beobachten wir jetzt Folgendes:
Eineiige Zwillinge
haben einen ähnlicheren IQ
als zweieiige Zwillinge.
Und das, obwohl sich die
Umwelteinflüsse zwischen Zwillingen
nicht groß unterscheiden dürften.
Daraus können wir schließen:
Intelligenz ist teilweise erblich.
Und weil man jetzt bei Zwillingen
den genetischen
Verwandtschaftsgrad genau kennt,
also 100% gleiche DNA
versus 50% gleiche DNA,
kann man damit
jetzt genau ausrechnen,
wie groß dieser
genetische Anteil genau ist.
Hier kann ich nur wieder
auf das Intelligenz-Video verweisen.
Schaut euch das bei Gelegenheit an.
Hier rechne ich es genau vor.
So: Bei Homosexualität
ergeben solche Zwillingsstudien,
je nach Studie
und Datensatz, Folgendes:
Die Unterschiede in sexueller Neigung
oder in sexuellem Verhalten
sind zu 20-50% genetisch bedingt.
Das bedeutet, ja, Homosexualität ist,
wenn auch nur teilweise,
genetisch bedingt.
Also ist die nächste Frage:
Welche konkreten Gene sind
denn genau dafür verantwortlich?
Kann man anhand der Gene so etwas wie
einen Homosexualitäts-Faktor ablesen?
Oder, platt gesagt, kann man
vorhersagen: How gay are you?
Jetzt wird's spannend.
Fangen wir an mit den Basics:
Unsere gesamte
genetische Information,
der ganze Funktions-
und Bauplan unseres Körpers
ist in unserem Genom
niedergeschrieben.
Das Genom besteht
konkret aus 46 Chromosomen,
bzw. aus 23 Chromosomenpaaren.
Wir bekommen ein Chromosom-Set
von unserer Mutter,
eins von unserem Vater vererbt.
Das ist ein
typisch männlicher Chromosomensatz,
wo das 23. Paar
aus 2 unterschiedlichen Chromosomen
besteht. X und Y, kennen wir ja.
Bei einem typisch
weiblichen Chromosomensatz
wäre hier
ein Paar aus 2 X-Chromosomen.
Jedes Chromosom besteht
wiederum aus einem DNA-Molekül.
Ein DNA-Molekül
kann man sich vorstellen
wie einen sehr langen Faden.
Bilder von DNA kennt ihr ja.
Das sieht normalerweise
nicht so aus wie diese Chromosomen.
In diesen Fotos,
müsst ihr euch vorstellen,
dass die DNA-Fäden, ich sag
mal so stark aufgekrumpelt sind,
wie dieser Faden hier bei Lars.
Dadurch kommen die die DNA-Fäden
zu ihrer Stäbchen-Form.
Jedes DNA-Molekül ist wiederum
aus 4 verschiedenen
Bausteinen aufgebaut,
aus 4 verschiedenen Nukleotiden.
Die Nukleotide
unterscheiden sich darin,
wird diese Base aussieht. Es gibt
hier nämlich 4 verschiedene Basen:
Also A, T, G oder C.
Mit diesen 4 Buchstaben
ist unser Genom also "geschrieben".
Also je nachdem in welcher
Reihenfolge diese 4 Buchstaben
sich zur DNA zusammensetzen,
ergibt sich
so unser individueller Bauplan.
So: Unsere Chromosomen
oder unsere DNA
sind aber nicht dasselbe
wie unsere Gene.
Die Gene sind Teil
unserer Chromosomen.
Die Gene sind die Abschnitte der DNA,
die die Bauanleitung für
ein bestimmtes Einzelteil enthalten,
z.B. für ein Enzym
oder einen Rezeptor.
Wenn jetzt eine Eigenschaft
genetisch, erblich ist, heißt das:
Eines oder mehrere Gene sind
von Mensch zu Mensch unterschiedlich.
Und das führt dann zu kleinen
oder großen Unterschieden darin,
wie ein Enzym, eine Zelle
oder ein Körper funktioniert.
Und das führt zu kleinen oder großen
Unterschieden zwischen Menschen.
Wenn ich also ein Gen finden möchte,
das für eine bestimmte Eigenschaft
verantwortlich ist,
kann ich schauen,
welche Stellen im Genom
bei Menschen mit dieser Eigenschaft
anders aussehen als bei Menschen
ohne diese Eigenschaft.
Dazu muss ich "nur"
das Genom möglichst
vieler Menschen entschlüsseln.
Es ist inzwischen technisch möglich,
das gesamte menschliche Gnom
Buchstabe für Buchstabe abzulesen,
man sagt dazu
auch das Genom sequenzieren.
Nun ist es aber
in der Praxis ziemlich teuer,
solche vollständigen
Genomsequenzierungen zu machen,
zumindest zu teuer,
um das jetzt für große Studien
massenweise durchzuführen.
Einfacher und günstiger
kann man das Ganze gestalten,
wenn man nicht das gesamte Gnom,
sondern nur einzelne
Buchstaben betrachtet.
Letztendlich
ist der Großteil unseres Genoms
zwischen verschiedenen Menschen
eh identisch,
da wir ja alle Menschen sind,
aber in unserer DNA
gibt es viele Stellen,
an denen ein einzelner Buchstabe
ausgetauscht sein kann.
Also ein Mensch hat da ein A,
ein anderer Mensch ein G.
Diese einzelnen Stellen im Genom,
die von Mensch zu Mensch
unterschiedlich sein können,
nennt man SNP's, die Abkürzung
für Single Nucleotide Polymorphism,
übersetzt: die Vielgestaltigkeit
eines einzelnen Nukleotids.
Diese SNP-Stellen
sind deswegen so interessant,
weil sie mehr als 90%
der genetischen Unterschiede
zwischen Menschen ausmachen.
Anstatt jetzt also das gesamte Genom
Buchstabe für Buchstabe abzulesen,
kann man auch einfach
diese SNP's betrachten
und schauen, welche einzelnen
Buchstaben an diesen Stellen sitzen.
Das nennt sich nicht mehr
Sequenzieren, sondern Genotypisieren.
Und das wird in modernen Studien
für mehrere 100.000 SNP's
gleichzeitig gemacht.
Und damit kommen wir
zu der erwähnten Studie
über die Genetik von Homosexualität.
2 verschiedene Datenbanken
lieferten den Forschern
Daten von rund 500.000 Teilnehmern.
Zu diesen Daten
gehörten Genotypisierungen,
sowie Antworten
auf verschiedene Befragungen.
Damit wollte man herausfinden:
Welche SNP's unseres Genoms
stehen in Verbindung
mit Homosexualität?
"Jetzt ist die Frage,
wer ist denn homosexuell?
Oder ab wann ist man homosexuell?
Beschreibt das
die sexuelle Orientierung
oder das sexuelle Verhalten?
Ist damit jemand gemeint,
der nur auf Sex
mit dem gleichen Geschlecht hat?
Zählt auch jemand dazu, der ab und zu
Sex mit dem gleichen Geschlecht hat?
Oder vielleicht Leute,
die das niemals ausleben,
die sich aber zum gleichen
Geschlecht hingezogen fühlen?
Fraglich, ob man das auf Basis
der praktischen sexuellen Auslegung
definieren kann."
Die Forscher entschieden sich dafür,
Sexualverhalten zu untersuchen.
Nicht unbedingt, weil das
der beste Indikator dafür ist,
ob jemand homosexuell ist oder nicht,
denn, wie Kostas auch sagt,
nicht jeder hat
die Freiheit oder den Mut,
seine sexuelle Neigung
auch auszuleben.
Aber für das Sexualverhalten hatten
die Forscher den größten Datensatz.
Alle Teilnehmer
hatten nämlich angegeben,
ob sie schon mal Sex
mit einem gleichgeschlechtlichen
Partner hatten.
Anhand der Antworten teilten die
Forscher die Teilnehmer in 2 Gruppen:
Wichtige Info schon mal,
um die Studie zu verstehen:
Es wurde hier
nicht Homosexualität untersucht,
denn Homosexualität lässt
sich ja nicht darüber definieren,
dass jemand mal Sex mit jemandem
vom gleichen Geschlecht hatte.
Das ist den Forschern
übrigens auch klar.
Und da zur Gruppe 2
auch alle Menschen reinzählen,
die einmal Sex mit
dem gleichen Geschlecht hatten ...
# I kissed a girl and I liked it
... müssen wir davon ausgehen,
dass man hier nicht nur
genetische Besonderheiten findet,
die mit Homosexualität zu tun haben,
sondern vielleicht auch
mit Offenheit, Abenteuerlustigkeit,
Risikofreudigkeit.
Das sind alles
Persönlichkeitsmerkmale,
die ebenfalls
teilweise genetisch sind.
Trotzdem wollten die Forscher wissen:
Gibt es genetische Unterschiede
zwischen den beiden Gruppen?
Und ja, die gab es.
Die Forscher konnten
einzelne SNP's identifizieren,
die statistisch signifikant
mit homosexuellem Verhalten
verknüpft waren.
Wer z.B. auf Chromosom Nr. 7
an einer bestimmten Stelle der DNA
ein G statt ein A hatte, hatte
mit einer höheren Wahrscheinlichkeit
schon mal Sex mit einem
gleichgeschlechtlichen Partner.
Von solchen statistisch signifikanten
SNP's fanden die Forscher 5 Stück.
Aber "statistisch signifikant"
heißt nicht automatisch "groß".
Das könnt ihr euch generell merken.
Hier das beste Beispiel dafür:
Der Einfluss dieser 5 SNP's,
also dieser 5 DNA-Stellen,
war zwar groß
im Vergleich zu anderen SNP's,
aber der Gesamteinfluss auf
das sexuelle Verhalten war winzig.
Es ist wie,
sagen wir alle MaiLab-Abonnenten
machen jetzt gemeinsam
eine Sammelspende
für einen guten Zweck.
Und jeder spendet
im Schnitt 1 Euro.
D. h., wir kommen zu einer
Gesamtsumme von über 500.000 Euro.
Jetzt spenden wir als Team,
Melanie, Lars und ich, am meisten,
z. B. 20 Euro.
Dann haben wir mit diesen 20 Euro
natürlich viel mehr gespendet
als der 1-Euro-Durchschnitt,
aber bei einer Gesamtsumme
von über 500.000 Euro
können wir uns mit unseren 20 Euro
keinen Riesen-Einfluss
auf die Kappe schreiben.
Bildlich gesprochen konnten
die Forscher mit diesem 5 SNP's
also 5
20-Euro-Beiträge identifizieren.
Aber selbst mit 5 × 20 Euro erklärt
sich noch keine 500.000-Euro-Spende.
D. h.: Es gibt sehr viele SNP's, also
sehr viele Einzelstellen in der DNA,
die sich
in ihrem Einfluss alle summieren,
die aber jeweils
einen nur sehr kleinen Einfluss
auf das sexuelle Verhalten haben.
Polygen bedeutet, es hängt von
verschiedenen Genen gleichzeitig ab.
In diesem Fall sind es
sehr viele verschiedene Gene,
die jeweils nur einen
sehr kleinen Einfluss haben.
Aber Komplexität hin oder her,
unsere Gene haben einen Einfluss.
D. h.: Kann man jetzt anhand der Gene
sexuelles Verhalten voraussagen?
Die Forscher haben es versucht.
Man kann nämlich für jeden SNP,
also für jede charakteristische
DNA-Stelle, berechnen,
wie dieser SNP
die Wahrscheinlichkeit verändert,
dass diese Person mal Sex mit einem
gleichgeschlechtlichen Partner hatte.
Also man geht dann
die SNP's einzeln durch.
Also SNP Nr. 1,
hier finden wir z.B. Buchstabe A.
Dadurch
wird die Wahrscheinlichkeit erhöht.
SNP Nr. 2, hier finden wir T,
so wird die Wahrscheinlichkeit
erniedrigt usw.
Das macht man dann für ganz
viele SNP's, für mehrere 100.000,
und am Ende bekommt man
so 'ne Art Gesamtpunktzahl
für die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
den "Polygenic Score".
Leute, es lohnt sich, so ein bisschen
was über Polygenic Scores zu wissen,
denn es gibt immer
mehr Anbieter und Unternehmen,
die genau mit den Polygenic Scores
irgendwelche Services anbieten,
die nicht selten fragwürdig sind.
Z. B. angeblich perfekt
personalisierte Ernährungspläne
auf Basis deiner Gene.
Ob jetzt so was Quatsch ist oder
nicht könnt ihr nur einordnen,
wenn ihr
die wissenschaftlichen Basic kennt.
Also: Die Grundidee hinter
so einer App "How gay are you" wäre,
ich reiche DNA-Sample ein,
eine Speichelprobe,
daraus werden die SNP's bestimmt.
Mit denen wird
dieser Polygenic Score erstellt.
Und je höher der Score,
desto wahrscheinlicher ist
für mich Sex mit 'ner Frau.
Das Problem
bei solchen Polygenic Scores ist,
dass sie sehr ungenau sein können.
V. a. wenn wir sehr viele SNP's
haben, deren einzelner Einfluss
auf die zu untersuchende Eigenschaft
so winzig ist
wie in unserem Fall
homosexuelles Verhalten.
Beim Scoring kommt
bei jedem einzelnen SNP
ein gewisser Fehler hinzu.
Und je mehr SNP's wir
in unsere Betrachtung miteinbeziehen,
desto mehr Fehler
summieren sich auch im Endscore.
Man kann aber
auch nicht pauschal sagen,
dass Polygenic Scores
generell Mist sind
oder dass es generell
nur eine vage Raterei ist.
Es kommt wirklich auf
die zu untersuchende Eigenschaft an
und auf die Größe des Datenpools.
Also es gibt Bereiche,
in denen Polygenic Scores eine
ganz gute Voraussagekraft haben,
z. B. bei der Zucht von Nutztieren.
Bei homosexuellem Verhalten
ergab der Praxistest nun Folgendes:
Menschen mit höherem Polygenic Score
gaben tatsächlich mit einer
höheren Wahrscheinlichkeit an,
dass sie schon einmal Sex
mit einem gleichgeschlechtlichen
Partner hatten.
Aber,
trotz statistischen Signifikanz,
war diese Assoziation sehr klein.
Die Polygenic Scores erklärten
nämlich in diesem Praxistest
gerade mal 1% der Unterschiede.
D. h.: Wir können zwar sicher sagen,
dass homosexuelles Verhalten
von vielen verschiedenen
Genen abhängt, aber:
Und jeder, der was anderes
behauptet, behauptet Quatsch.
Wie zum Beispiel
die App "How gay are you".
Die App wurde inzwischen
übrigens runtergenommen,
denn die Ersteller
bekamen einen Riesen-Backlash,
v. a. von den Studien-Autoren,
die die Falschdarstellung
der Forschungsergebnisse
scharf kritisierten.
Übrigens auch
den perfekten Ernährungsplan
kann mit Polygenic Scores nicht
erstellen. Spart euch euer Geld.
Welche Konsequenzen zieht man
nun aus dem Studienergebnis?
- Ehrlich gesagt
ist das das beste Ergebnis,
was ich mir hätte vorstellen können.
Denn einerseits
beweist der genetische Anteil,
dass Homosexualität nicht
eine willkürliche Entscheidung ist,
aber trotzdem ist er so klein,
dass er nicht missbraucht
und gegen Homosexuelle
verwendet werden kann.
- Noch etwas ist ganz wichtig:
Anders gesagt:
Umweltbedingt ist viel mehr
als nur Erziehung oder Erfahrung,
es gibt
auch biologische Umwelteinflüsse
wie z.B.
der Hormonstatus im Mutterleib.
Z. B. steigt bei Jungs
die Wahrscheinlichkeit schwul zu sein
mit der Anzahl ihrer älteren Brüder.
Eine mögliche Erklärung dafür
ist der Einfluss
über das Immunsystem der Mutter
während der Schwangerschaft,
der mit jeder
Jungs-Schwangerschaft größer wird.
Also das wäre jetzt
ein biologischer Umwelteinfluss.
Der Junge selbst
hat keinen Einfluss drauf,
liegt aber auch nicht in den Genen.
Heißt: "Born this way" - "ich kann
nichts dafür, wie ich geboren werde",
bezieht sowohl Gene
als auch Umwelt mit ein.
Die Vorstellung, dass Homosexualität
eine "Lifestyle-Choice" sei,
ist also definitiv falsch.
Wir wissen, es gibt definitiv
einen genetischen Einfluss.
Und dass es weitere
biologische Umwelteinflüsse gibt,
ist nicht auszuschließen.
- Wenn man selber homosexuell ist,
wird man immer wieder mit
so blöden Kommentaren konfrontiert.
Leute, die sagen,
es sei gegen die Natur oder so.
Und das ist ein handfester Beweis,
dass es nicht so ist.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das
Leute, die selbst gerade dabei sind,
ihre Sexualität zu entdecken,
Sicherheit und Angst nehmen kann,
weil das zeigt:
Sie haben darauf keinen Einfluss und
müssen sich nicht verrückt machen.
- Trotzdem sind
die ethischen Bedenken
bei dieser Forschung
noch nicht vom Tisch.
Ich hoffe, ihr erkennt, dass
ich hier mit meinen Hintergründen
einen Regenbogen darstellen wollte.
Ich weiß, ich habe nicht alle Farben
und v. a. sind sie nicht
in der richtigen Reihenfolge.
Tut mir leid, I tried.
Es gibt heute schon Unternehmen,
die bei einer künstlichen Befruchtung
deinen "besten" Embryo
für dich raussuchen wollen.
Dafür werden
auch Polygenic Scores benutzt.
Die hier wollen z.B. Embryos
mit erhöhtem genetischen Risiko
für Bluthochdruck aussortieren,
oder welche, deren
Polygenic Scores darauf hinweisen,
dass sie besonders klein wären.
Selbst die Auswahl des "besten"
IQ's wollen sie in Zukunft verfolgen.
Noch ist die Antwort ja zum Glück:
Das bringt alles eh nichts.
Also diese Designer-Baby-Idee
ist technisch gar nicht umsetzbar,
weil die Polygenic Scores
viel zu ungenau sind,
übrigens selbst bei Eigenschaften
wie der Körpergröße,
die eine sehr
starke genetische Komponente hat.
Aber die Forschung
entwickelt sich hier rasant weiter.
Umso wichtiger finde ich es,
dass wir uns
jetzt schon darüber Gedanken machen,
wie wir damit gerne umgehen möchten.
Denn es gibt ja auch schon
heute technische Möglichkeiten,
die diskussionswürdig sind.
Also jeder Schwangere
kann heute in der Pränatal-Diagnostik
feststellen lassen,
ob das Baby Downsyndrom haben
wird oder nicht und ggfs. abtreiben,
was krass ist.
Also wir haben
diesen Test nicht gemacht,
weil wir das Baby
so oder so behalten hätten.
Stellt euch vor,
man kann in der Pränatal-Diagnostik
irgendwann
alles Mögliche feststellen,
z. B. ob das Kind eine Risiko
für Homosexualität hat.
Also das wäre für mich oder
für uns als Eltern total irrelevant,
aber das sehen
ja leider nicht alle so.
Was denkt ihr? Gibt es Forschung,
von der man lieber
die Finger lassen sollte?
Oder ist mehr Wissen immer besser?
Falls ihr selbst queer seid
und durch dieses Video vielleicht
zum 1. Mal auf MaiLab gestoßen seid:
Herzlich willkommen,
bleibt gerne hier,
wenn ihr euch
für Wissenschaft interessiert.
Schaut auch gerne bei Kostas vorbei.
- Ich bin Kostas.
Ich habe auch einen Kanal bei Funk.
Zurzeit beschäftige ich mich
relativ viel mit LGBT-Themen.
Abgesehen davon
zeichne ich sehr gerne,
ich interessiere mich
für Animation, ich lebe vegan.
Auch zu den Themen
werdet ihr immer wieder
was auf meinen Kanal finden.
Wenn euch das interessiert, würde ich
mich freuen, wenn ihr vorbeischaut.
Ich hoffe, dass euch
dieses Video gefallen hat.
Vergesst nicht den Daumen
nach oben zu geben
und auch diesen Kanal zu abonnieren,
denn Mai und ihr Team
machen einfach die besten Videos.
Danke, dass ich dabei sein durfte,
denn auch ich bin
schon lange Fan von diesen Kanal.
Echt cool, dass wir
jetzt mal zusammenarbeiten konnten.
Ich hoffe, es geht euch gut,
bis zum nächsten Mal, haut rein.